sounds good so james going back to it so
i i asked you when there was no sound
how does it feel knowing you're both
loved and admired by your core audience
but you also got a lot of people that
hate what you're doing how does that
feel i i it's humbling it's uh i'm sort
of wit
i don't really focus on the fear and i
and i think that then one of the things
i read about this book american
muckraker is the is the sort of
characteristics inherent in in my
colleagues and myself is that we're sort
of very tunnel vision so we don't really
focus on those things we know that
they're there we take rational steps to
deal with them but we're kind of focused
on what we do
some tells me it doesn't bother you
though some tells me you're comfortable
with opposition
i i didn't ask for the opposition
sometimes i don't understand the
opposition
um but it's there and uh i don't let it
affect our decision-making so so would
you call yourself a whistleblower or a
is it a muck-raker muckraker is the term
i think is best to find us and some
people don't know what that means it it
means someone who publishes information
that the powerful people do not want
published versus publishing information
they give you to publish how different
is that than a whistleblower or is it is
much raker
somebody who goes and recruits other
whistleblowers as muckraker somebody
that goes against the institution
how would you explain the difference
between the two well i think a a
muckraker is a
term
you know historically from 100 years ago
teddy roosevelt coined it
it could be all-encompassing um the
whistleblowers that we work with don't
are not my employees they don't i don't
uh pay them salaries we have people on
full-time staff but a muckraker is
effectively anybody who can
expose what's going on the real truth
the hidden hidden truth
so it is an element of being a
whistleblower it is an element of
somebody who wants to expose people who
behind closed doors are playing
essentially the game of uh what do you
call it the the puppet masters you're
trying to expose some of those guys yes
we're trying to expose that with the
powerful people in a world where
the fbi and the new york times and
pharmaceutical companies and all these
they're just acting in concert
it takes kind of an independent
citizen group of people that are just
the ordinary folks to expose it yeah and
it's it's
the the concept of citizen journalism
is on fire right now where people are
becoming the journalists due to
this one weapon and tool that we all
have right here i don't know if you saw
this guy
that plays for manchester united the
soccer player what's the guy's name have
you seen the story with this guy what's
been happening to him so this guy pull
him up manchester united soccer player
uh a
soccer player it should pop up
uh oh there it is right there go to the
second one greenwood mason greenwood
there's a video of him
and an audio of his girlfriend recording
their conversation having sex it's such
a
weird and by the way he got fired i
believe they just let him go
and he's being accused for certain
things he she's saying i don't want to
do this and he's saying don't make me do
this and then there's videos of her
bleeding with like you know he hit her
in the face and next you know they let
her go meaning this thing is probably
one of the most scariest or most
powerful weapons that we have today
folks if you don't know our guest today
let me kind of give you an idea who it
is who he is uh james i had a chance to
read your book yesterday and uh
uh finish it this morning i listened to
the audio of it uh new york times
bestselling author you wrote your book i
think it was called breakthrough yes
breakthrough um he's got a organization
he leads called project veritas which i
believe you started at 2011 or maybe
2012.
one of those two years is when it kind
of started growing yes uh and he's
exposed a lot of different stories uh if
you remember the one story with abc
when abc news amy roback was caught on
hot mic saying network
spiked jeffrey epstein's bombshell and
she was trying to do this story and the
story was leaked by you the video that
was one of the stories that project
veritas did uh there's another story
having to do with
uh i mean there's a list of them google
executive recently the one you did with
the federal government nurse i believe
that was talking about vaccines and the
one video you showed they're sitting
there saying this person took their
ninth or eighth shot or seven shot or
whatever it was you exposed big pharma
you did something with the senator pro
antifa high school teacher in california
admitting communism indoctrination of
students and the list goes on and on and
on senior google manager on search
engine power said you are just plain and
simple trying to play god the power in
the search trump says not something
misinformation you're gonna delete it if
a democratic leader says it then you're
gonna leave it so you've done so many of
these things going after pfizer going
after all these guys and here's here's
what i've learned about whistleblowers
you know everybody loves a whistleblower
on their side
and everybody loves the whistleblower on
the opposing side
because you know as kids
what are we raised to do hey don't
write don't
tattletail don't snitch but
there's a different uh
snitches get stitched yes let's just say
stitches but you grow up and you're
sitting there you're thinking you gotta
protect the whistleblowers but are they
really doing good there is this dispute
that goes back and forth with people on
both sides when it comes down to
whistleblowers
how do you view
the the
life of a whistleblower the how we view
whistleblower should people look at him
as a hero should they look at him as
divisive how do you how do you view
whistleblowers well i mean i i that
there's this book there's a chapter in
this book american mock record called
insiders and and uh to be whistleblowers
to step outside the great chain of being
to not to join not just another religion
but um but another world and sometimes
this other world is called the margins
of society but it feels like outer space
the metaphor that
ellsberg used famous 20th century
whistleblower it's like being an
astronaut you cut your umbilical cord
you're not part of
the institution you worked for you're
not part of my institution you're sort
of floating out there but i think
i think in in this world today um
i was just watching joe rogan's uh
instagram video as i was coming into the
studio what did you think about that
dude
what was going through my head is this
quote from orwell that freedom is the
freedom to say that two plus two make
four if that is granted all else follows
rogan said in his little instagram video
he said you know i
six months ago or a year ago they would
have banned you for saying these things
and now they're the scientists come out
and say it's true
so it's just we're living in this
bizarre dystopian reality where
you can't call this a bottle of water
and and and they say experts say experts
say who are these experts
so
we have to we have to show people the
reality we can't tell them what they
really have to show them we have to
allow people to trust the evidence of
their own eyes and ears
and that's the sort of journalism that
we do we don't ask you to trust us by
virtue of the fact that i declare myself
credible that's what they do experts say
experts say
we don't ask you to trust us or trust
the whistleblower the whistleblower
shows you the evidence right first
person observation journalism such that
you can see it for yourself they don't
want you they don't want to trust your
eyes and ears and we would ask that you
do that and that's that's what was going
through my head as i watched that rogan
uh comment he made got it yeah so by the
way when you mentioned daniel ellsberg
he was what he was a former
uh of a government employee pentagon
papers uh 7 000 papers he turned in i
think he gave it to new york times and
20 other papers
and he was you know looked as a hero
three years later
they stopped the vietnam war and then
afterwards nixon came back with
espionage you know laws against him and
uh i think the same thing obama tried to
use against someone as well right obama
used against uh during the obama
administration uh president obama
was really putting the screws to
journalists i'm not sure the new york
times would publish the pentagon papers
these days i think things have changed
in 50 years i mean
we released a story involving literally
pentagon papers two weeks ago involving
uh darpa documents and i cannot
obviously disclose who the source was it
was not
major joe murphy the author of the
documents was not our source but but
those people don't they can't go to the
washington post or the new york times
anymore they don't know who to go to
there's not many organizations for them
to go to except project veritas
yeah you know your opening of the book
you say what you say i get asked two
questions the most right and
i'll focus on one of the questions one
of the questions is how are you not uh
you know worried for your life i don't
remember exactly how you posed the
question but you know the fear of your
life yeah do you feel for your life
you're going everywhere you're pushing
the envelope i mean
pfizer is a pretty
massive organization to go up against
right you're going against abc
mainstream media
uh the institutions you're talking about
the swamp all the politicians the people
of power
you're essentially calling them out and
making them look like fools you did you
made zucker look like a fool when you
were on his conference caller not mark
zuckerberg but i'm talking about jeff
jeff zucker cnn so you know
how how safe do you feel i mean you got
raided by the fbi early in the morning
where they come in with 10 people with
flashlights in your eyes and they're
taking your two iphones in the journal
that you had of biden's i believe
what was a daughter's
journal that it was
how do you feel do you wake up in the
morning worried about your life
well i
i'm glad that you read the book and i
appreciate you reading the book cause a
lot of people don't so i i respect you
for listening to the book and bringing
up a lot of these anecdotes so i know
you read it uh the first chapter this
book called suffering and you might say
what are you writing about that in a
journalism book because
it's kind of a premise here that you're
going to go through some pain if you if
you speak the truth and i think people
are so afraid i don't understand it i
never have i never
i i don't i don't think i'm a sociopath
but i do think that one has to be a
little bit of a masochist to do this if
you think about it
um and i and i really tried to meditate
and i really i mean it took you five
years to write this book i i spent weeks
uh in the mountains literally in a cabin
a couple weeks uh last year during the
pandemic trying to answer this question
you know the two most common things is
yes do i fear for my life and the second
most common question is what can i do
you probably hear that a lot i don't
know what to do how do we solve the
problems and what people mean when they
say what can i do is i think what victor
frankl wrote in in in man's quest for
meaning survivor of the holocaust you
know which is
how do i find meaning in life and i
think as we enter this weird dystopian
reality where two plus two equals five
where this bottle of water is not water
it's coca-cola
i think i think people are trying to
they're putting more of an emphasis on
meaning rather than their own
self-preservation that's what i see in
my life in other words
people are less concerned about
materialism and
and um
and money and they place more of a
primary value on their conscience and i
think we have a choice to make in this
life and i quote alexander solzhenitsyn
who jordan peterson you know introduced
me to through his podcast i read this
gulag archipelago carefully and i
thought about it and there are some
comparisons to what he wrote about in
the soviet union that you can follow
your conscience
and give up your livelihood or you can
maintain your livelihood and sacrifice
your conscience and these are the two
choices we have to make and i think more
people now than ever right this very
moment in time are willing to follow
their conscience into the gates of hell
why because we believe we believe in the
truth and will do anything for it and i
wrote right about in this chapter uh
suffering that like any survivor of
psychological abuse the american mock
breaker starts to realize a new kind of
superpower reborn through baptism by
fire he is invigorated by the knowledge
that he is no longer a slave to fear
that's what i went through i stopped
being a slave to that because i went
through these experiences to to do this
uh james there's got to be
somebody that pissed you off right i
mean to do this there's got to be
somebody that either offended you or
uh uh you know because i looked at your
parents they were conservative but not
at the levels that you are you know i
kind of saw what their beliefs were they
were they were leaning right as well
but did somebody offend you did somebody
upset you used to be a writer at your
school and then you went and decided to
start your own paper instead of write i
think was called centurion i don't know
what it was maybe it was called
so so it's not like you know
what was the one event i mean maybe even
we can go back to high school if you and
i were in 10th grade 11th grade
who was james o'keefe that's a great
question um
uh
i can answer it in two different ways by
talking about that but i think as a
teenager i remember being young young
man and and certainly in college i read
i was very fascinated by journalism i
would read the newspaper every day new
york times i i love and star ledger i'm
from new jersey so that's i don't even
know 10th grade you were reading the new
york times i mean he went to rutgers so
this guy's been well in college
particularly i was obsessed with reading
the newspaper now this is 20 years ago
and or 19 years ago and these newspapers
are becoming a shell of themselves
they're basically like you know exit
skeleton they throw ap articles in there
but this star they they provided a free
copy in college uh at rutgers public
university in new jersey of the star
ledger us today new york times i would
sit there in the dining hall every
morning because i was a shy introverted
kid and i had no friends my freshman
year and i would read front to back all
those three papers and i considered that
my education i was a philosophy major
but i was i was religious about reading
the news and i was fascinated by it
and as a teenager i don't know maybe
13 14 years old i would i would watch
local news so i grew up in the new york
city suburbs of new jersey and i would
watch the the broadcast and just i just
felt intuitively
that how they were portraying things
were not as things were so
things were not portrayed as they were
and rarely as they ought to be and
that's the best way i can describe it
it's just sort of a
and i know everyone knows what i'm
talking about because now it's
self-evident the news is not showing you
how things actually are
they're describing reality and it
affected me i remember i remember it
affecting me and i didn't know i was
ever going to do anything about it i
didn't i didn't think that i'm going to
be a journalist i didn't even know
frankly what a journalist was or what a
journalist did and i certainly had no
inclination of going to journalism
school
and i was in boy scouts i was a an eagle
scout actually and when i was about 18
years old they had this board of review
conference where you go before your
scout master
and they asked me what do you want to do
with your life
and i went on this rant about
things because i was trying to look for
guidance
and uh and he said and i said i said
things are not what they seem and and
and rarely as they should be
and he said have you ever thought about
going into journalism
and that was the first time anybody ever
said that to me and i and i thought
about that and i didn't know what it
meant to be a journalist and then i went
to college and i read these papers every
day and i was literally reading the new
york times run to back and i got angry
at the new york times i said that's not
right that doesn't seem you know this is
right after 9 11 and the world events
that were happening and the op-ed pages
so i decided to um uh write a column for
what was the daily rutgers newspaper the
daily targum it was called and i wrote a
column and i started
and then i researched how the ratio of
democrats to republicans of the
professors at the university and the
ratio was a hundred and four to one the
imbalance of it and the imbalance of it
affected me too and i said well that's
not right
there should be more ideological balance
among the faculty and and then we can
talk more about what happened next but
that was the the initial origins so the
reason why i asked that is you know adam
you know he's
been a comedian before and then from
there he went into business and has done
well for himself you know when you think
about comedians you'll typically the dna
of a comedian is a what somebody that
maybe lived a rough life so humor was a
way of you know just what's the word or
where
a lot of comedians have dealt with
issues
tremendous yeah so then you you think
about like ufc fighters like gsp or some
of these other guys their
lineage to wanting to become great
fighters was what they were bullied as a
kid so there was a form of
them being bullied bodybuilders same
thing
what what did somebody piss you off did
somebody bully you or did somebody did
you live a rough life did you see
somebody right in front of your eyes
betray somebody and lie and they went to
jail or something happened to them we
said i just don't think this is right
good question i remind you a question i
think was candace owens asked me what
happened to you or maybe it wasn't her
but someone said something someone did
something why does that question keep
popping up though no it's actually only
the second time i've been asked the
question and i and i'm not a
psychologist i i but i let me attempt to
answer it um the only thing i can say
about my childhood
before this teenager watching local you
know fox5 new york news was
my grandfather and father i was raised i
did have an unusual upbringing in the
sense that i was doing property
maintenance with my my father and
grandfather i'm the third james o'keefe
iii my grandfather um would wake me up
in the morning and we'd go do what work
on the houses every morning paint and
landscape and do roofing and plumbing
work and
i guess it it was looking back it's like
kind of like a
child uh slave labor i don't resent it i
think it's it's it was formative and
taught me values and hard work but i did
not like the work um i never took to it
uh uh and we would work all weekend and
every night during school
and and we we
you know i told the story before but
since you asked um
uh you know that was very formative for
me it was a sort of indefatigability
that
my grandfather and father instilled in
me very tunnel vision so we would work
on these homes doing everything
ourselves we didn't hire any labor
um and for years starting at five years
old i would i would do manual labor with
my father and grandfather every weekend
dirty disgusting work and they didn't
make small talk with me
my father never never did i wanted to
but we never made small talk we just
work work work work work and and i hated
doing the work i i just tested it i'm a
very creative person i always have felt
that
and i would daydream during the work and
i would think about things but i was
forced to do this
so my only and i'm not a psychologist
i'm speculating here but i i suppose
that
they instilled in me something i
didn't necessarily have when i was born
which is this
tunnel visioned almost maniacal drive
although they gave me that
but my my passion was different than
you know you know pvc pipes and and uh
roofing my passion was we was exposing
and artistic so when you combine those
two things but i don't no one ever
really pissed me off it was more just
the hard work that i did that i guess
instilled in me james uh you know pat
asked that question to quite a few
people like who were you in high school
because i think what you do is very
unique very unique it's not like
who else is like james o'keefe it's like
i don't know not that many people well
thank you i guess well yeah i mean it's
very unique what you do whether people
you know love what you do or
ardently oppose what you do but i think
the reason that he's trying to get to
this is like trying to understand who
you are and used a couple terms that i
want to ask you about you said yeah i
guess i am um
would you uh masochist masochist and
then you said and you said something
that was i kind of caught me off guard
and i don't want to gloss over it you
said as a freshman i
had no friends and i sat there and read
the newspaper yeah and for me that's and
even for pat that's always been a person
that's thrives on camaraderie and
friendship and banter and joking
and having fun like that
you were
i don't want to use a loner but you said
you had no friends and your friend was
the newspaper and you started to develop
these beliefs and these thoughts so i
think that's ultimately kind of where
pat is going is like
why did you have no friends how did
having no friends
lead to basically where you're at now i
don't know i don't know if i'm qualified
to answer that question well there's
nobody else more qualified than you
today i like this question all i can do
is give you the facts yeah what what my
life was like and maybe someone can draw
conclusions i i didn't i was a sprawling
state university it was you know 50 000
people
um i was in the dining hall every
morning reading this newspaper for hours
and then but over time i did i made
friends over time i maybe built an
organization here with
70 plus employees i've
i've i've kind of start you know started
with nothing and we've no now i over the
years at in college i even built a
little newspaper there a magazine and i
built a staff
but in the beginning there yes there was
was i guess you could say i was a shy
introverted guy and were you not looking
for friends this is like for me i guess
the reason i'm harping on this is i've
always been a person that i don't
collect toys collectibles watches
clothes i collect friends and people
that i really enjoy spending time define
friend
yeah that's a very good question because
you know how they say you know keep your
uh circle tight you know so i i have a
handful of best friends but a large
network of people i could call at any
minute you clearly have developed that
now but that wasn't that case my
grandfather
james o'keefe senior irish irishman and
by the way he used to call me irish
funny enough he he called you yes he
called me irish he would drag me out of
bed at whatever time ungodly hour and
i'd be digging some ditch with my
grandfather is that why you tried to
cancel the lucky charms leprechaun
that was i think that was a coincidence
i mean i was an irish american that was
good right we could talk about that
solid respect yeah he would he would say
you can only count he did
we did we did it
in the dining hall with the box lucky
charm said i don't look like the
leprechaun on the front seat of the bug
it was a form of satire with satire well
you tried to get rutgers to cancel them
or even
you know give a response as to why they
were not going to cancel him irony is
now dead so people don't understand
irony and we can get into that but it's
like i went in there with a with a box
of lucky charms and i said and it was
very hard to keep his straight face
i really struggled
i said you know we're not all short we
have differences of height i don't look
like this
and they told me they'd remove lucky
charms i put the bureaucrats in a bind
there but my grandfather used to tell me
you know you can you can only count your
friends on one hand i mean people say
that so i did define friend people in
fraternities you know people join
fraternities and that's no criticism but
some people say you buy friends through
a fraternity and friends and i've been
through so ups and downs in my life that
i mean insane highs insane lows i mean
incarceration uh
jon stewart daily show south park
episode about our journal i've seen such
highs and lows that for me it's like
i've seen people come and go and their
loyalties are so i don't like phoniness
i never i don't i don't know how to be
phony i don't i don't like politics i
don't like politicians so
i i think that you don't like politics
no i'm definitely no politics is
horrible really
yeah let's let's transition let's
transition so here's here's a
here's my here's my question for you so
um
to do what you do
you have to think like
whoever the enemy and the the opposition
is meaning
if i'm gonna go out there and uh
go against the
dirty manipulative deceptive
tactics that are out there i almost have
to match them don't i because you know a
lot of times you'll talk from uh
you'll sit down and have conversations
with the left or the right
and the the the right will say
the left is just extremely manipulative
and what they do and they're willing to
go and play such dirty tricks and look
what they did in chicago with jfk and
dewey and they'll they'll get the votes
they'll get this they'll get that
and then uh some people say well we have
to play their games against them to beat
them right
and then you'll have faith-based folks
will say we're just not gonna cross the
line that's not what we're gonna do
we're gonna stick to it
but i think there's a part of it where
you know the whole saying goes if you
want to wrestle if you wrestle with a
pig
you know you kind of get some mud yeah
yeah but the point is if you're gonna
wrestle with a pig you're gonna you have
to have some kind of pick tendencies you
have to play their games against them
did you ever in your mind say look
you guys all want to play square and you
want to play safe i'm going to go
against these guys and i'm going to use
their strategies against them i'm going
to piss them off was that kind of
a line you had to be willing to cross or
this is the line you're going to come as
close to the line as possible but not
across it i don't know if you understand
the question i'm asking i understand i
understand what are your thoughts on
that well there was a professor in
college named david knowlton
and he introduced me to a man named
saulinski and and david knowlton was i
don't know if he was a professor or an
adjunct guy but he was a businessman
lobbyist who taught a class and i took
and
any any any there's rules for radicals
by saul and scandal if you've heard of
this book sure there's a line in this
book it's called rule number four make
them live up to their own book of rules
now that sounds sort of machiavellian
and twisted but it's just a simple it's
really another way of saying it is
expose their hypocrisy
so and olinsky says it i think he said
in this rules radical's book you know he
was talking about christians and it's
hard for them to live up to their own
standards it's hard for them to live up
to the bible for example but you can
apply that to anything
and i read that line in that book rules
for radicals
which is now transformed into something
just sort of journalistic but at the
time there was on campus they had these
uh
speech codes they called them you can't
offend anyone for any reason you know
you can't you can't say anyone that say
anything that offends anybody and for me
that was a slippery slope
i just viewed it as twisted i said you
can't offend anybody well the whole idea
of
college is to
is to exchange ideas
so that's what led to the lucky charms
thing where i said
okay well if i can't offend anybody well
then why don't i say this box of lucky
charms is racist against my irish
heritage
and and it was i was like a form of
satire i guess or you know exposing it
but now what what's what this is
involved in is and i want to draw a
boundary is it absolutely not do we do
what they do
uh we do not lie to our to the people we
do not deceive the audience we do not do
the things that they do we do
sometimes use deception in the sense of
a pretext with our subject in other
words
in journalism circumstances can arise in
which deceit towards the subject is less
wrong than other possible courses of
action including being so honest with
your subject such that you are dishonest
with your audience in other words if i
come to you let's say you work for the
pentagon and i say hi i'm a journalist
tell me all the fraud you're committing
and you give me some canned line
and then i publish your line to the
millions well now i'm lying to millions
of people but if i pretend to be a
telephone repairman and i'm in your
office and we're talking and i record
you right you don't know it well i've
just
lied to you about who i am but in doing
so i've gotten some truth which i
broadcast to the people and they'll
attack me o'keefe's a liar he uses
deception and undercover i say it's a
question of relative deception
and and in this business in journalism
you have a choice to make so i it wasn't
so much that i was obsessed with
undercover and wanting to do this these
things that seemed manipulative
i we wanted to do whatever we needed to
do
to get to the truth we had to dig deep
we had to learn how to use disguise and
pretense and these things that were not
comfortable these are not comfortable
things to do
you don't like
doing them in fact i could tell you in
that in that lucky charms video
my heart was beating 160 beats per
minute i it didn't i didn't you know
wasn't comfortable
uh performing in this way to get to get
this information did it feel did it make
you feel like i feel like i'm being a
little bit deceptive and dirty or no
you're kind of like listen i'm gonna
match you
i'm gonna match you at this i'm not
gonna lie i'm not gonna do this but i'm
gonna play all the games necessary to
get as close to the line as possible no
it felt uncomfortable it felt
uncomfortable but the best i can say is
it felt uncomfortable but necessary i
remember confronting the professors i
had printed out these certificates and
you know
this is all irony and satire like
think of it like borat meets 60 minutes
that's the best way i can describe it it
was like bull rat okay i'm going to go
in there i'm going to pretend to be this
so i can expose the reaction and expose
the
the the the speech policies
i felt so uncomfortable
i forced myself to do it i forced myself
to do it it's like you know doing
something you hate doing frankly like i
had to stick my little child armed on a
sewage pipe i i just forced myself to do
it because i said this must happen i
must do this you know do you have a
family or no
no
kids my parents and my sister no kids no
children any plans of ever having kids i
would love to have kids so you would so
it's not like you don't want to put him
through what you're going through where
your kids go to school and maybe you
name him after james o'keefe and hey is
your dad james o'keefe he is and
so you're comfortable having kids and i
put them through i would like to have
kids okay fantastic well that's good to
know so so going back to that you know i
asked this question because
okay so one you you you once to prove
the point about the border you dress
like osama bin laden i don't know if you
can pull this up you dress like osama
bin laden and you cross the border to
prove a point
to say here's how bad the border is if
you can go to images and david if we can
show this this is james o'keefe okay
right there to the right if he can show
that
another time i think you went in uh uh
acting like you're a pimp with a
prostitute right who was there that you
were trying to expose that was that was
a group called acorn and you expose them
and you this is an organ organization
that had been around since 1971 500 000
something correct you know members that
they had and right afterwards six months
later you you pretty much shut down the
organization at the time when you did it
was 07 which is 15 years ago you were
what 23 years old 24 years old yeah so
so this is what i mean by like these
strategies and tactics you got to have a
creative mind to say i'm gonna play your
game against you yeah but and i think i
i think i answered that in so far as
that we do whatever we need to do to get
the information and and and for the
acorn story that i could we could spend
30 minutes to talk about that story but
in a minute it was it was this young
woman who messaged me on facebook like i
get most of these tips these days from
the citizens and she said what if you
went in there as a prostitute and this
was a this is a government you're
telling her she's telling me she's
giving me this idea on a facebook
message in 2009
and we get our tips and ideas and at the
time i was i was nothing i had no money
i had no organization i was just a
filmmaker with these ideas and she had
seen what i did with planned parenthood
and said why don't you go in there as a
prostitute and we're having this i've
never met this woman before we're just
talking over facebook i said well there
probably should be a pimp and what
occurred to me is how brilliant it was
because this is an organization that was
doing illegal things squatting
foreclosed homes they were they were
accused of doing corrupt acts so if you
went in there and said you were a
criminal and you had
a deviant business you would you would
get a reaction now i thought that they
would
i assumed i had my hypotheses was that
they would perhaps tell us to evade the
authorities or something something
mildly you know fraudulent when i went
in there in baltimore and with my hidden
camera embedded in my satin tie with
with hannah was dressed like a she was
from miami she was from miami a 20 year
old dressed like a
she had stilettos and a sarong and a
leather halter top they told me how to
disguise the underage hookers as
dependents on the tax returns they
brought in the accountant this was like
this was like something out of a you
know an snl skit
but they actually wanted to help us
evade the law
and and it it got quite serious it got
quite serious very fast i mean those
videos uh prompted congress to defund
acorn democratically controlled congress
so it wasn't me
that destroyed or defunded acorn it was
the united states congress there we are
there's hannah that's what she looked
like she went in there now i did not
wear that fur coat in every office uh
but she wore that in baltimore by the
way prostitutes prostitutes do not look
like that in baltimore but these workers
wanted to help us
and we did this in uh baltimore dc new
york uh
san bernardino los angeles every office
helped us but won
now i gotta tell you you're sitting here
right across the room you don't look
like a pimp it'd be very hard for you to
pass as a pimp but that picture right
there you got very close to looking like
a pimp
a low budget one but he does look like
one thing's for sure his pimp hand is
strong regardless well it was just it
was so low budget uh people at the time
this was a massive story i don't know if
people remember it but it was it was big
um and the late andrew breitbart
described it like taking the penthouse
to the uh glass elevator all the way to
the top with with the what we did and i
might i did not have any money so that
that fur coat was my grandmother's coat
the hat was my grandfather's hat hannah
accoutred herself and we drove around in
my old my old jalopy grand marquis and
uh we just did it i mean we just two
kids from the cast of high school
musical three question for you so some
people will say look
you know if you're really gonna do the
whistle blower stuff why don't you go
after both sides because at least sasha
baron cohen will go and expose
you know maybe ten percent of people he
exposes is the opposing side you know he
did something with bernie sanders his
own side uh i think he went after bernie
i don't know he did something different
i mean there's something to go after
especially with the last year there's no
question about the people from
to those who ask that question is this a
pure crusade
you have against the left or is anybody
that does
uh uh uses their power against people to
manipulate defi i i think we need to
define these things when we say side
what do we mean we say left i'm not even
sure what that means anymore because i
have the fbi working with the new york
times is that left wing
let's define reality there's only one
reality there's only one truth veritas
does 24 24 frames per second or now it
on the iphone with the high definition
it's 64. i don't know what how many
frames
truth at 24 frames per second there's
only one reality there's only one truth
our medium is to film things film people
talking and often times we don't feel
any you see their lips moving so that
happened it's an event
over time you'll see us do everything we
just did a video on alex stovall's
republic in arizona he's a republican
running for congress and he said one
thing in private and another thing in
public he contradicted himself and we
exposed it
and we were not condemned by the right
in fact
my that reaction that story it seemed
like
[Music]
people on the right appreciated it even
more because they didn't want people on
their side uh when i say right
republican party if that's even right
wing so i'm not sure what i what we
there he is uh uh project veritas action
exposes flip-flopping arizona
congressional this was a guy who said uh
privately
that there wasn't enough fraud to
overturn the election and publicly that
there was so he so i'm not saying he was
wrong by saying privately what he said
it was the fact that he contradicted
himself but that that would still be
seen as one side though
i mean if he's against uh a
fraud for election
and then he says it that is a that is
against the the the idea of many people
on the right
however many you want to say that
thought the election was a fraud so for
him to flip that i don't necessarily
think i put him as a
person who would essentially be
on the right to defend some of the
philosophies you got to keep in mind
this is a show where we defend
capitalism this is a show about you know
a person who escaped iran to go to
germany i lived at a refugee camp i'm a
kid who grew up in a communist family in
an imperialist family mother's side they
were all communist dads that were
imperialists but it's it's more it's
more strong to say listen here's what
we're doing we're
covering up the guys on the opposite
side i'm not a comedian i'm not sasha
baron cohen here's what we're doing this
is what we stand for this is where we're
going uh but at the same time there is a
big audience out there that will say you
target mainly once and and you know what
they're gonna say that until they stop
saying it because we have people coming
to us now like like i say the darpa the
the marine corps major who wrote which
by the way there's nothing wrong with
that i mean you're going against if
you're going up against the government
that's well what you stand for but
here's two two quick responses here's
the irony of them saying i go off to the
left by exposing cnn there's an
admission there are you saying that cnn
is left are you saying the new york
times is left is the fbi left is our
federal bureau of investigation left are
our pharmaceutical companies left is
this guy left so at a certain point that
argument is it's over what's going to
happen there's an asymptote on the on to
or a mathematical analogy that asymptote
will approach
you know zero and and people are going
to come to us they can't go anywhere
else
cnn uh
the network cnn gives a deliberate false
impression daily they they they say the
two plus two equals five we got a guy at
cnn saying
quote where propaganda the control room
director he said we're propaganda and
he's talking about the death numbers on
the screen his name was chester charlie
chester
c-h-e-s-t-e-r this is probably one of
the biggest investigations we ever did i
was most proud of this one and he goes
why can't it be higher we need the
deaths to be higher more people from
kova need to die so we have higher death
numbers higher death this is what this
guy is saying i didn't say it he's
saying it you can see his lips moving
he's being secretly recorded at a bar
so these networks there it is quote if
it wasn't for cnn i don't know trump
would have gotten voted out now i did
not entrap him
we did not tell him to say these things
we asked questions
i did not ask leading questions
our undercover people said tell us about
what your network is like we're
propaganda we get trump out so if that's
my question is a rhetorical one
why won't the people at cnn say that
publicly
say what say the fact
if it wasn't for cnn trump wouldn't have
gotten voted out quote where propaganda
quote why won't the death numbers be
higher there's nothing by the way i'm
not making a moral judgment about that
right and i won't
that's something about me that's
different than all the other journalists
you see on tv
i'm not making my only judgment is this
my only rule is this
don't say something privately
if you are a powerful man like that that
you're not willing to say publicly okay
so we both know that happens in your
organization that happens in our
organization that happens in every media
every sports team every business every
company
there's going to be certain things
you're going to talk about
uh aspirational behind closed doors
where for example tom brady every time
they interview him after he wins again
this is what tom brady will say
you know we have to respect those guys
on the other side we have tremendous
respect for the coaches that's right you
know
jimmy g and the kicker for san francisco
what's the kicker's name
do you know what i'm talking about the
kickers
yeah
you know we respect the guys on the
other side the green bay packers have a
world-class organization and then you
see the clip that they recorded on [ __ ]
the backers yeah did you see that one
part so listen who doesn't do it i think
everybody does it partly on the other
side because
to compete at that level especially
media you have an enemy cnn's enemy is
fox fox's enemy is mainstream media
msnbc has an enemy everybody's got an
enemy and quite frankly everybody's
mainstream media's enemy right now is
joe rogan who is kicking everyone's ass
so there is an enemy in every place so i
think there's a part of it okay i'll
give you another question so one of the
stories that goes
talking about you is the fact that uh
james o'keefe has made 1.9 million
dollars since 2011 right and they show
your income okay okay and it goes from
which to me the income is 400 000 your
income whatever it was in 2020 or 2021
we have the exact numbers based on the
article
and he says you're one he raised it was
a small thing he raised only four
hundred thousand dollars and he has a
job where he was working 60 hours a week
or 80 hours a week making 50k year
before i think the article you've read
before and it goes he raised one million
dollars he raised two million dollars he
raised four million dollars now he's
raising eight million dollars 12 million
dollars and eventually it was a 20 i
think you raised 21 million
in 2020 whether it's 2020 or 2019 you
raise something like 21 million dollars
right and then in the book there's a
part where
they call you out and they say
well who are the backers
who's given the money to project veritas
there's an article that says koch
brothers there's an article that says
names that comes out about you right and
then your position was
i think it has been
uh
by law to not release the information of
uh the guy the individuals who give
money to our organization you said
something like that in your book right
and i'm sure you know what i'm talking
about
so so you know
again you do you want people to know who
gives money to your organization do you
want the public to know who you give
money to the organization
it's a
fundamental right enshrined in the first
amendment freedom of association so
there's a distinction there in that uh
there's a chapter in this book called
secrecy and i talk a lot about this
there's two things there's three things
that we can keep secret and there's no
other secrets one of those is the the
donor donors to our non-profit which by
the way don't tell us what to do
it's a freedom of association right
enshrined in this case uh naacp versus
alabama supreme court justice john
marshall
economic reprisals loss of employment
threat of physical coercion and
manifestations of physical hostilities
those there's a quote from the united
states supreme court you do not want to
disclose
donor identities to organizations
philanthropic news organizations be
precisely because of the fear and the
intimidation and surveillance sure
quite different than
charlie chester at cnn admitting what
his actual
and what the actual uh motives and
agenda
are
um and if i was doing that people should
expose me because these people have a
tremendous power
and it's their and it's their ability to
manufacture the public's consent
you know i think the informed consent in
this country is critical in the american
founding and this sort of jeffersonian
ideal of the public's right to know
which makes us much different than any
other country in the history of the
world perhaps right and the american
experiment in the american ideal that
people have to have access to actual
information and the only way for them to
do it by the way i'm a 501c3 of the
economics of project veritas you're
right people talk about how the money we
raise we have 100 000 donors that give
us this money i started with nothing i
mean
they were saying i was funded by
right-wing billionaires when i literally
was broke and and destitute
like where were you did you ever
so i was so broke with that acorn store
i took the chesapeake bay bridge because
it was four dollars less people thought
i was nuts yeah so they project what
it's all about so the story about koch
brothers that's a lie that they never
participate in helping you out with the
project veritas we don't disclose our
donors i mean for all you know hillary
clinton is funding us it doesn't matter
well that would change the story that no
now you got babylon bees got a story
tonight
but it wouldn't change the story because
the re the things that we're presenting
are real
and and upton sinclair you know people
forget that like you know nelly bly and
sinclair and lincoln stevens they were
all socialists and you know what more
power to them if you have an agenda like
this but what you what you shouldn't do
is you shouldn't deliberately mislead
and give a false impression to your
viewers it's not as much the motive or
or your political agenda yeah it's that
you tell a deliberate untruth to people
it doesn't matter who's funding you it
matters whether you're deliberately
telling an untruth
yeah so for example like this story the
the forbes story that was written
november 11 2011 which was a couple
months you've read this article you're a
guy that follows this stuff
uh 1.9 million since 2011. okay that's
what that's 10 years 11 years i don't
care how much money you're getting paid
for that so you made 400 000 last year
after you live in what state by the way
you live uh west chester new york okay
so you're broke is is what it is i'm
serious with you if you're making 400
grand you're in new york 50 you got 200
left to yourself well here's an
interesting thing about economics
because i think it's a fascinating
question we're a full philanthropic news
organization now you know they're a
billionaire uh chairman of media
companies we've settled lawsuits we've
never settled the lawsuits it'll cost me
two million dollars to get the jury
verdict in the court case two million
i could have we could have given to
someone fifty thousand dollars and
settled the lawsuit
why would we not do that well if you're
a businessman if you're if you're if
your imperative is cash money if you
want to keep money in your pocket you're
a masochist if you look at this and say
i could spend 50 000 to make the lawsuit
go away or i could spend two million
dollars go through discovery go to trial
and i might lose yeah and we've never
settled a case and that's why our legal
bills at veritas are
some some years five million dollars a
year five million
and all proceeds from this book goes to
our organization to pay our reporters
salaries but the economics of journalism
there's no business model for
investigative reporting
it's self-evident
all of the corporations have slashed
their investigative bureaus because it's
too expensive
it's it's too painful and that's why our
our model is the 501c3 the non-profit
philanthropic model i mean the story
continues to say well mother jones
liberal magazines pays its president
only 225
and they generated 16.6 million the
daily caller news foundation which
publishes conservative content online
pays their chief development officer 138
can they keep going with all these other
stories judicial watch another uh
right-leaning crew pays its treasurer
395 000 and they go probably anyways
they're telling all these stories here's
here's kind of where where i'm going
with this uh part here so if somebody
from your own organization went out
there and said listen i work for james
the other day he offended me because he
made a joke that really upset me he made
a comment about the chiefs losing and
how excited he was and how dare you say
anything about pat mahomes right i have
access to all the people that give
here's a list i give it up you wouldn't
care you'll be like okay that's part of
the whistleblower game which which list
the the uh whoever the the donors are to
you that i would part of that i wrote a
whole chapter in this book about this
and i'm and i'm writing a a book about
journalism ethics i'm writing a manual
because no one has really ever done this
before so i'm trying to define
the boundaries and this is a very
critical point there are only two things
we keep secret
because really because really
underlying your your line of questioning
here is this notion of hypocrisy like
james o'keefe you probably you're cross
to bear you probably do things in
private and my answer is listen
i we all make mistakes we're all human
but there are two things that so help me
god i will not disclose because it is
enshrined
in the fundamental values that we hold
as americans which is number one the
rights to protect our sources
and the right to protect our donors by
the way if the united states supreme
court were to order
me
to reveal who released that document
from the pentagon i would be held in
contempt of court and go to jail to
protect my source
i would like jack anderson the legendary
muckraker from the 1970s i would i would
submit to your honor that you're an
error
and i would not i would not oblige with
that and i would and i would this is i
would be
i would i would have to face
incarceration in perpetuity rather than
disclose my source this is this is
enshrined in
the dna of the first amendment you don't
disclose your source and you don't
disclose if the naacp to borrow an
analogy um
in 1958 were ordered by the supreme
court to disclose who donates to the
you know an organization that protects
the rights of african-americans that
would that's what that case was about so
when you when you ask me what if they
published your information i'm sorry but
so help me god there are two things i
will never disclose and i cannot
disclose oh by the way because to do so
would be anathema to the very to the
very things that give us the first
amendment in the first place okay
so no no no donor has ever been
of course the people that are trying to
disclose these donors don't share
a
faith
in these principles they don't like the
first amendment and and and that's the
only public policy issue that i take a
stance on anything else i don't really
have a
political views but on this
on this
here i stand i can do no other and
that's why i wrote that chapter called
secrecy because i meditated on this and
i realize
everything else i have to have
disclosure on
and by the way we do file a tax return
and we put it on our website do you know
any other news organization that does
that no we do we we publish that 990 we
we disclose everything we go through
discovery and litigation i've been
deposed more times i can count by the
way i like depositions i have a good
time being deposed you know why because
i got nothing to hide you know who
doesn't like being deposed the new york
times they're scared of that you know
why because they have everything to hide
and that's the difference really that's
the difference between project veritas
and anyone else so on those two things i
i would never want to disclose them and
i will fight to the death to not
disclose so so i i uh support your
decision for doing that and i'm i'm
part of that uh
uh understanding that it like for
example the other day somebody messaged
and they say hey did you know patrick
david gave to the following
organizations and he gave money to this
and this and he was at this event i'm
like i was what do you want me to do
where did you get this information from
well this person told me that you did
this
okay so on one end if somebody wants to
release it they release it on the other
end this is privacy for
who i want to give to and that part of
it has been compromised a little bit
right now but you said something you
said uh you know never disclose the
source right the word never disclose the
source if if you've if
comma if you've promised confidentiality
to the source of the information but
don't you think that can be abused
abused by uh both sides meaning hey uh
yeah i think that yours are mine
something's happening okay all right so
like the the hey this dossier we got
on trump's uh meddling in the elections
with russia but it's a it's a source we
cannot tell you who the source is
because we have to protect the source
right isn't that something that's abused
to constantly say
we cannot disclose the source of both
sides come out and trump will come out
and say we have to find out who the
whistleblower is you know when that took
place when he was coming out and then
schiff will come out and say you know
the history of protecting whistleblowers
in america we have to protect these
whistleblowers it's always protect the
whistleblower when it's on their side
and it's always exposed the
whistleblower and the source when you
say besides i again i i hear what you're
saying i know you don't like identity
politics
my whole mission is to fight against
that but
well i hear what you're saying but but
i'm living in a normative world i i
understand that that is the current
status quo
when i was raided by the fbi the aclu
defended me which was so shocking to to
right wingers it almost made their heads
explode they couldn't fathom this okay
like oh the what what party appointed
the judge that ordered the fbi to stop
well it was an obama appointed federal
judge
and i reject the premise that we have to
live in this world of sides because
there is only one truth now you're right
i'm not saying you're wrong you're
you're actually describing the current
series of events where when the
whistleblower comes out against trump
who we want to know who it is
but
yes and no i think there are some people
that are
that are so political that they they let
their politics get in the way of these
values these primary values of bart
nikki v vapor a supreme court case from
2001 when you want to live
in a society which places a primary
value on freedom of the press it's a
concomitant of life
you you have to live with this notion
that if the source gives you a document
from inside the pentagon or wherever the
white house
it could be the cleaning lady whoever
you protect the the identity of that
person
and the reason some have said the reason
why
the aclu defended me after the the feds
raided my home in november was because
they didn't want to happen to them sure
under a descent administration
so so there still is in the venn diagram
of the you say side integrity a little
bit of integrity there's a there's an
overlap between the left and right in
this country yeah and it's that overlap
that that little
overlap that gives me hope in fact i
want to expand the overlap when the aclu
defended this there you have it when the
ace of different that was a beautiful
moment that was probably one of the most
beautiful moments of my life
um because
i said to myself there are we are
finally talking about principles
we are talking about the things that i'm
going to sound like a hippie here so
forgive me but i believe i actually
believe this the things that unite us
are so much more powerful than what
divides us they ask us to focus on our
divisions but that right there is
beautiful that isn't that's an
incredible moment
and and then you have to say why is the
aclu defending james o'keefe and that's
the real conversation that's the
beautiful conversation that makes us
american that makes this country
wonderful because we give people
information and we don't disrupt the
right of people to get the information
all right so so this is where bill maher
wins because bill maher says
be very careful with the censorship game
you're playing because it can come back
and bite you in the butt when the
administration changes right so you see
bill maher coming on and some people are
saying well bill maher is becoming too
conservative you know bill maher's
becoming way too conservative he went
out there one time he said look i took
the vaccines i took it and i got coveted
i don't i don't know what to tell you i
i did what i was told to do and i still
got so you kind of start to see some of
that stuff taking place you're starting
to call out the people on the left just
as much as you would typically call the
people on the right yeah
about that this past week he says 30
years ago the reason why comedians do
well making fun of the right is because
that was funny yeah he says try making
fun of pelosi what the hell are you
going to say about polos he says but
today today's left is making it easy for
the right to make fun of the life he
specifically said i haven't changed i'm
still the pot smoking non-married making
fun of everybody you've changed exactly
so the only thing i'm saying that my
point only the only point i'm making to
you is you know again going back to the
fact that the whistleblower who comes
like snowden remember when he came up
with the 30 000 emails and people were
like well this is not cuomo said this is
not the right thing to do yeah you know
this is just not right you don't do that
kind of stuff some of this information
doesn't protect the level of hypocrisy
on both sides against each other when
they use the tactics against each other
that's when the american voter who i
believe james america is run by the 12
of voters okay not the ones that you
know they're gonna when you're saying
identity identity politics those on one
side that no matter what you tell them
they're gonna vote left those on one
side no matter what you tell them
they're going to vote right i think
america's run by 12 i think you're right
that 12 is who we have to win if we win
the 12 over and they sit there and say
you know what i don't know if i like
those two stories james it but this one
i kind of have to agree with them well
your your point about leaks i i there's
a part of this book american muckraker i
talk about this this idea of leaks
whistleblowers and and and i think the
the the distinction the qualifiers if
you can see the information yourself so
snowden when he brought those dogs you
could see the documents right you
weren't really relying upon ed snowden's
credibility as a witness the documents
were self-evident
my problem is when the anonymous sources
right say well you know people familiar
with the matter
i think i think you have a point a
source is familiar with the matter
we don't have any reason to trust the
washington post when they tell us that
we don't know who these people are so i
agree with you if they don't show us the
evidence okay and an analogy i would
draw is when you use an anonymous source
which veritas doesn't really i don't
think i've ever
ever reported something without showing
you the evidence i don't say well you
have to believe me because i say so
when as a journalist when you say you
you're withdrawing from the atm of your
credibility
but you've got to make deposits
sometimes into the atm deposits evidence
but the new york times and washington
most don't actually give you any
evidence here's an example the trump tax
return story that this was a story about
a year and a half ago that was
concurrent to one of our stories that we
did the new york times published a story
but they didn't print one document they
didn't show you any pictures they didn't
show you any evidence they asked you to
believe them because they are the new
york times
when i saw the new york times for
defamation
it came out in court in court documents
in the deposit in the discovery rather
in the in the uh answer to our
defamation lawsuit it came out that they
admitted they got the facts wrong in the
article and they refused to update their
article that means that right now on the
internet there's an article
it's on wikipedia
facebook uses it as the fact check
that's wrong and they admitted in court
it's wrong but it has not been updated
now what is that if not disinformation
so when they accused joe organ of
disinformation the new york times in
court saying we got it all wrong and
they haven't fixed the article which
remains on the internet
it's literally an orwellian dystopia
so when they say believe us because
people are familiar with the matter tell
us that this is so
there's no reason for you to believe
them unless you can see it for yourself
so again the rule is and i write about
this book this is i'm creating a rules
for journalism
don't trust the anonymous sources unless
they show you unless they've given you
the actual raw evidence and have a track
record of showing you raw evidence every
once in a while
there there is a uh what's the there's a
rule when you go to journalism school
whatever school may be i mean obviously
colombia is one of the biggest ones but
they're pretty much politically on on
one side what is the level of
accountability that journalists have
none no but there is though there used
to be i mean if you go back years ago
they were held accountable for certain
things that they were supposed to
investigate the truth then you're
supposed to tell both sides here's what
this side is doing here's what this side
is doing and if you're wrong you come
out and apologize there was four things
journalists were held accountable to uh
uh
according to the what is the journalism
uh journalists uh organization out there
there's do you remember when we talked
about this like a year and a half ago
um anyways i don't remember that's kind
of like the hippocratic oath for
journalism yeah the the the they have
something uh society professional
journalist has a has a a code uh i can't
recall the the rules of this code
but uh i think the press has an
important
obligation to police itself the media
has no self-policing mechanism
so the press you know there's a need for
self-examination and
a degree of open mindedness to the
criticisms that are leveled against it
but what's happened i think it's about
integrity
um
and there used to be a lot of libels
lawsuits act people forget the 1980s you
know 60 minutes was sued many times many
times now the rub on me is that they
attack me for being sued i've won every
lawsuit so we can talk about you won
every losses every single one you have
never set a lawsuit personally
myself james o'keefe not project guard i
settled a lawsuit before project veritas
was created i never set a lawsuit again
we thought we won every case but media
settle lawsuits all the time
i mean cnn or uh washington post settled
with nick sandman that was the young man
with the native american in washington
dc and they're not attacked for it
they get away with it well they were
called out for that though they were
definitely wrong and they had they were
held to the fire on that do you consider
yourself a journalist
yes i mean
to more specific specifically american
muckrakers
again depends upon what your definitions
of these things are would you say that
you're a supporter of donald trump
uh am i a supporter of i support maybe
some of the things that he said or did
done but uh i i have to remain
independent and nonpartisan well the
reason i ask is because you've been an
advocate for journalists that you've
when you got raided by the fbi you
basically in so many words said this is
ridiculous journalists should not be
treated like this but i saw a clip of
you
speaking on a podium with a big banner
trump in the back it was a trump event a
dinner of some sort and you said we must
go after the media yes absolutely so i'm
just trying to understand if okay so
you're at a trump event you're speaking
you're the speaker i suppose it's a
trump event you're saying going after
the media so i know you've been pretty
bold on saying look left right i don't i
mean who even knows at this point yeah
you know you brought the example of 104
professors are
liberal uh you know
what is conservative out of balance
but ultimately i think what pat was
asking was like if you do 100 stories
kind of 99 of them are against the quote
unquote left you could easily find
trump's tax return stories you could
easily go against steve bannon he's been
held
you know sure and so i guess my question
is like
he you know i don't know if there's an
answer to your question you may not like
it
i don't have an agenda here i'm asking a
question it's self-evident the first the
first moment does not protect defamation
in the the new york times versus
sullivan case establishes the actual
malice for defamation you can't you
can't lie about a public figure so when
i say go after the media
it is it is consistent with first
amendment principles to expose what the
media is doing wrongly that's consistent
with the first moment the first note
does not cover intentionally lying to
people so when we say i mean i think one
of trump's virtues something i did like
about the president was this
highlighting the fact that we shouldn't
necessarily trust everything we're told
by these media and by the way don't take
my word for it you can look at our
stories on cnn and the new york times
we've exposed these people that have
admitted they're lying to people and
that's not that's not what the first
amendment was designed to do when
jefferson talked about we need
newspapers more than we need government
um
it goes back to this this this ideal and
by the way i've also spoken at duquesne
university i've spoken to groups that
are hostile to me and behind me was
you know duquesne university and marty
baron and dean bakke and and if and if
the aclu wants to have me speak i'd love
to speak there i'll speak anywhere i
will speak as my mother and sister once
said to me if there's only one person
who's going to listen to the truth that
you need to speak you speak it
so if the if a key west uh republican
group wants to have me or if uh duquesne
wants to have you or i don't know what
we're referencing there but any place
with the banner behind me pbd podcast if
i can if i can speak these principles
i will speak them and i and i agree with
with certainly some of the things that
trump has said about the media yes
okay so how about we now that we've done
a lot with you let's go into some
current events if you're okay with that
i don't know what the protocol is but
would you mind if i take a bathroom oh
go for it you go 60 seconds you go um
you'll be the third person in the
history oh okay i guess i've done this
you just ended up on the soy boy i'm
sorry i know go for it go maybe this is
a moment maybe i'm being exposed
i'm on the record here i say we follow
him to the bathroom make sure he's not
checking any notes okay no no i'm not
i'm trying to hydrate it after my
project veritas musical i'll be right
back do you know where the bathroom is
okay all right sounds good while you're
doing he's the third member now you were
the first tom was the second guy he's
the third yes have you done it twice or
have you done it just once okay so
here's what we're going to do when he
comes back we're going to cover the
joe rogan spotify neil young story as
well as harry and megan who urged
spotify to stop covet 19 misinformation
will cover that we'll cover all the
different names that came up with willie
nelson bruce springsteen barbara steis
streisand queen paul mccartney rolling
stone david grow a bunch of guys that
are going against spotify we'll also
talk about canadian truckers but
meanwhile you and i why don't we talk
about uh brady's retirement yeah he came
out and just said you know he hasn't
said it yet even his father contacted
david if we can close that door even his
father contacted espn tmz reported
saying look this guy has an announced
retirement he contacted the chief saying
listen not the the chiefs but uh
no no the bucks saying oh god look i
haven't made my decision yet where do
you stand do you think he is retired but
he's upset that story leaked yeah well
how could you think he's not retiring at
this point why would that even come into
the atmosphere and people talk about
could you imagine if that's actually not
true and he's like i'm actually coming
back
nonsensical brady is so maniacal that i
think brady
may have had a conversation with a few
people thinking about he's retiring and
that hey here's kind of the direction
i'm going somebody leaked it brady
behind closed doors is so pissed off
that they licked it because he's always
wanted to control the narrative he wants
to come out and say i'm retiring with a
video or a message you know how he
typically does it with a video that
comes out
and uh imagine if he flips and he says
you know what the hell with you guys you
did that i'm gonna go one more year if
there's anybody that can basically flip
it on us
it's someone that's basically saying you
think you're going to control the
narrative about me and my life no i'm
coming back we're going to run it back
yeah edelman came out and he said i'm
going to miss you babe or something like
that you know on twitter i said that
edelman oh julian edelman yes i'm gonna
miss you babe specifically babe
well he's a you know
they they got a little brilliant what's
going on over there but could you
imagine
if this is a quote unquote fake news
story james o'keefe type vibe where
you know we can expose the media for
getting it wrong yeah and next thing
you know he's coming back so ultimately
the question is do you think he is in
fact retiring
um uh
i i have to tell you i think the
conversations took place i think he is
so pissed off right now
i think he's so furious right now that
it leaked to anybody else i don't think
he's the type of guy that would want the
story to leak i think he's lost his mind
with being furious he wanted to do it
his way and it kind of changed it up but
you know there's some people that are
upset saying listen there's one because
we were at the birthday party it was the
the tico's birthday party when we heard
the announcement okay about uh 10 years
old 10 years old he'll turn 10 tomorrow
and uh people like no he didn't he
didn't retire yeah he did no he didn't
yes he did tmz saying he didn't so i
don't know do i think he's going to go i
think he can play one more year i think
he can play one more he led the league
in
yards yeah touchdowns uh but did you see
the completion did you see his last game
when he lost he was not going out
without a fight no no but did you see
it it almost was
you know you you looked at his face at
certain moments it was kind of like do i
like afterwards especially
do i really want to go through this one
more time because think about if you're
him right now here's what you're
thinking about
who are you going to put around me okay
i need a little bit more help
i got to hit a little bit too much okay
maybe antonio brown nonsense yes
receiver went out for the season he had
a couple other injuries like maybe he's
sitting there saying can i do this one
more time what other record is there
left for him to break but you actually a
week ago were saying there's something
about the way he did the press
conference you were there actually
that was writing
yeah no i think i think i've never heard
him speak that language you know when
somebody speaks a language like for
example you're sitting with your buddies
and somebody says not gonna lie to you
man you know i'm just sick and tired of
being married this is like freaking very
hard or i'm sick and tired of being
single you're like this guy's never
talked like this before there's
something going on there there's
something going on there okay folks we
got james back here okey for you a nfl
fan tom brady fan do you want to weigh
in on this retirement i used to be a
bills fan when i was growing up i loved
the bills a lot of elves in that
building that was eight nine years old
and they lost their fourth straight
super bowl i cried my dad had to say
it's just a game son
in 1994 they lost four scott norwood man
scott norwood
um doug flutie remember doug flutie of
course he was my hero in in high school
i loved boston college came out of cfl
no didn't he start off with uh i went to
a giant stadium then giant stadium in a
doug flutie jersey uh jets fans worst
fans
i'm dressed as a bills fan at giant
stadium and they're like throwing fluty
flakes at me and uh but i love doug
flutie he was my my favorite growing up
and i'm sad to see brady retired so i so
when i came to the states 1990 november
28th the football teams you had was
cowboys you had a few different teams i
was a die hard bills fan thurman really
oh bibi bryce paul wow andrea bruce
there was something unique about this
mark leaving every i was a bills fan
when i came to the states and i was a
lakers fan so for the first six years i
was in bad shape as a 13 year old kid
had therapy sessions twice a week you
know going through it do you remember
the game in 1999 with the the music city
miracle with the titans and the bills
yeah but there were the scores yeah that
crushed me yeah right i don't know if
and i think it crushed a lot
yes
that cro they benched doug flutie yeah
and put in rob johnson he lost his shoe
remember that game that was that was my
moment i i i never i used to love it
we've just figured out the spoilers game
do you remember the oilers game
frank reich or
listen my dad was taking me up to san
francisco we're driving up there we're
listening to the radio i'm like i'm
devastated they're down i'm like turn
off the radio i don't want to listen to
it we get to san francisco we get to a
restaurant to eat we look at the screen
it says the greatest comeback of like
you're right right
yeah it was the comeback 1994 yeah
something like that maybe this is this
freudian moment you want to know this
this 1999 i remember this game i was
obsessed with the buffalo bills in the
90s after this game it crushed me
and i know it crushed a lot of people
they benched my hero doug flutie
and they put in rob johnson
anyway so well i think we figured out a
few things here
now
the truth has been reviewed we've been
trying to you've elicited the truth
exactly we've been trying to make out
what makes o'keefe that's what pistol
it's the buffalo bill spelt b i l l l l
you got to send each other
do you have a flutie signed jersey or no
i had a fluted jersey yeah i did i used
to wear it to the the jets and the bills
were in the same conference and every
once a year in new jersey meadowlands i
used to go with my dad see him awesome
well you know the one thing about sports
is it typically takes you back to a
moment with your mom or your dad or your
brother or your sibling yeah do you want
to tell o'keefe the truth was doug
flutie come on and we brought doug
if you're watching doug all right so
let's talk about what's going on with
the freedom convoy in canada which is
going viral it's it's being talked about
everywhere except for mainstream media i
don't know if you've been following this
story or not let's kind of go through a
couple things that's going on there
folks
uh hundreds of truckers block ottawa in
freedom convoy to protect to protest
vaccine mandates it's a france 24 story
hundreds of truckers have uh blocked the
streets of uh central auto on saturday
as part of the self-entity self-titled
freedom convoy to protest vaccine
mandates required to cross the u.s
border flying a canadian flag waving
banners demanding freedom and chanting
slogans slogans against prime minister
justin trudeau the truckers were joined
by thousands of other protesters angered
not only by the covenanting restrictions
but by a brother broader discontent with
the government an enormous climb uh
clamor ring out of hundreds of uh big
trucks their engines rumbling sound that
their horns anyways i'm gonna tell you
this other store from al jazeera
why are anti-vaccine canadian truckers
covering
are converging in ottawa i like that
title right they're
anti-vaccine-canadian truckers so convoy
of antibiotics and canadian truckers and
their supporters making its way to the
country's capital ottawa
uh starting on january 15 canada has
required essential service providers
previously exempt from vaccination
requirements including truck drivers to
be fully vaccinated across the land
brought from the u.s unvaccinated
canadian truck drivers entering the
canada entering canada will need to meet
requirements for pre-entry arrival and
day eight testing as well as quarantine
requirement i keep in mind 90
of these truckers are vaccinated 77 of
the country
is vaccinated and this freedom convoy go
fund me if you can go to it as of last
night it was at eight point seven eight
point eight million if you just type in
freedom convoy go fund me they may be
over nine million dollars james i'm
assuming you're following you're
following the story what are your
thoughts on what's going on right now
with these truckers
uh you know
9.2 million 9.2 million people 9.2
million dollars raised
they haven't taken it down yet they've
taken it down no they haven't 113 000
donors but my first surprise is the
gofundme has not taken this down
um
but but i guess that it goes to show you
the difference between how the media
portrays things and how things actually
are because so many of these people in
canada believe in this and it's and it's
self-evident in the pictures you're
seeing like i said pictures evidence you
can see the trucks you can see the
so so they say it's fringe but that's a
characterization that doesn't seem
accurate that doesn't seem based upon
reality it does not seem fringe it seems
mainstream it seems that there's a
substantial minority if not majority of
people that agree with these people
so i what what i draw from from this uh
you know this sort of the orwell two
plus do equals four quote is that how
things are portrayed by the canadian
leadership and the media
are not as they actually are in in in
terms of the grassroots support for this
adam do you have thoughts on this well
that's what's the ultimate story here
they're just not they're protesting
mandates they're protesting mandates
some people that are protesting against
the mandates are fully vaccinated and
took the boosters and trusts they're
saying i'm fully vaccinated i just don't
want mandates okay so watching through
that mindset they're basically saying
look i did it i support it i mean
who dr robert malone who you interviewed
is vaccinated yeah he basically said i
almost got crushed by kovid yeah if you
can't show that video david if you can
pull up that video so people can see it
however i don't believe
in the mandate ultimately isn't that
what is this picture of here this is
ottawa those are the truths is that
currently yeah
are they wearing math i don't mean it's
a judgmental question are they wearing
masks are they willing to uh
uh
violate the the city protocol i don't
know here's crazies
so so guys the border is 5500 miles long
canada and u.s borders 5 500 miles long
okay you got these truck drivers which
the strangest thing is if anybody cor
their job is to quarantine it's truck
drivers they're by themselves driving
like that's it's not like they're around
anybody else they're driving unless
there's 99
of the time unless if you got another
person with you but you're driving by
yourself maybe with another person to do
your job generally
it's by yourself and they're saying if
you don't do this by the 15th to cross
the border to this is not just the
canada thing is that crosstalk are
crossing the border
canada canada
you're you're crossing the you know the
international borders you just make a
populist comment too something my friend
laura logan always says to me which i
think is very poignant and this this is
a visualization of this is really
amazing visuals we're looking here at uh
instagram videos is that they have
tremendous power and we're nothing you
know that's the comment i see people say
we're nothing we're insignificant we're
nothing but but lara says to me we're
not alone when she says we're not alone
and and we the people that's it's a
cliche it's a tale as all this time but
we are so insignificant compared to the
powers that be
that have the power of coercion and the
power of the you know the legislatures
but
this is a very amazing moment you know
that that we the people and even
canadians we the people by the way go go
to elon musk's tweet because ilamas
tweeted about the truckers and what he
said canadian truckers rule yeah
canadian truckers really said yeah
something like that uh so so think about
it this way who would have thought kyrie
irving okay
truck drivers in canada you got elon
musk you got
joe rogan you got the strangest camps
that are sitting there saying dude can
we just not be forced to do what you're
telling us to do i'll take the vaccine i
just don't want it before so i had a
couple people over at the house for the
birthday party and you know some of the
guys from the community very successful
business people and the conversation my
vaccine came up from them and i said did
you hear about tom brady what tom brady
i'm like did you hear about truckers
what truckers i'm like you're not
following the story no i'm not following
i read new york times in the wall street
journal journal every day and i've seen
nothing about trucker i'm like you got
to be kidding me zero so they're in
front of me kind of going through it
these are two professionals both of them
are c-suite executives running their
companies living in beautiful property
legit legit people they know nothing
about what's going on and so tell me
about interesting what are your thoughts
on vaccinations what are your thoughts
on this i said listen i think uh to each
his own i think it's
something that
probably helps minimize for certain
people my dad had covet and he had
pneumonia simultaneously and he had the
covet shot and he was able to go through
it at the age of 79 and he just took the
booster and he's glad to have it right
and then he says how about yourself how
about your employees how about this what
percentage of home office is vaccinated
they're in the health industry i have to
get everybody vaccinated one of my
friends got all their doctors and nurses
and i like to get them vaccinated 20 of
their employees and doctors just
resigned the city can't force us to do
this so there is a community out there
and they're finding each other and
they're sitting there saying look man i
just want you to
leave me alone don't bother me let me do
this by the way in canada things are so
strange in canada because one of the
reporters i don't know if you saw that
james he said look if we have to choose
between keeping you alive and feeding
you
we're going to lean towards keeping you
alive
like what did he should say you know
what he just said if we have to choose
between us not letting these truck
drivers do their job so food is not
being delivered to you these are
thousands these are 15 000 truck drivers
so food doesn't come and you don't have
enough food for a week or two or three
weeks
for us it's more important to keep you
alive from the co from kovit than feed
you
and we have to kind of go through that
and quebec is saying they're going to
start opening up movie theaters with one
rule you can't sell popcorn because they
don't want you to go in without a mask
on because they want nobody eating
popcorn in movie theaters yeah yeah this
so it's a very strange dynamic this is
what we talked about last time this is
more than just a health problem there's
an economic problem there's a
uh social societal problem you're
staying at home you're the depression
problem how many people are not getting
out of the house being able to exercise
you know we we
uh the quote i mean james has been
busting out quotes all day i don't know
who said this but he said war is too
important to be left to just the
generals
just like a pandemic is too important to
be left to just the scientists there's a
lot of business people there's a lot of
um
just
regular people who have a voice and have
a say
and it's not just one you know one size
fits all type cure to this and and look
what's happening again
cb radios or those are the radios that
use for the trucks are free from
censorship control zoom zoom in so we
can the audience can see what he's
saying go to the tweets
the reply elon musk there cb radios the
truck radios are free for media control
those are the old radios we grew up in
as with kids you know
even um
it's it's a very amazing one for me this
is all about i go back to the power of
the image i'm going to speak from a
journalistic perspective on this matter
not as a public policy health issue
it's the it's the idea that those are
profoundly moving images of a convoy of
trucks and thousands hundreds of
thousands of people there are tens of
thousands of people
and then the wall street journal new
york times you wouldn't even know about
it
if you lived in manhattan
that's strange if you only read the new
york times yeah if you only you would
not see it
that's actually really an amazing
observation there you wouldn't even know
about it
if you only read certain publications
and that's not right they don't want you
to see why don't they want you to see
the images because they want a
specialized class of men as edward
bernays said and
dean lipman said we need to interpret
the data we don't want you to have the
images because you might draw wrong
conclusions from the images that you see
well that's not right james other than
project veritas obviously what news
sources do you
trust any any source that i i can see
the evidence myself if it's your name
names
no because it's like because a broken
clock is right twice a day i mean anyone
can do this any
new york times can and has done good
journalism
but you got to be able to see it like
we're doing right now like we're looking
at the images assuming those images are
not doctored right there let's go go to
what denise said when dinesh was on with
us and i did the interview this is
exactly what i said i don't know why the
right isn't doing this we talked about
this on our interview maybe a year and a
half ago
he says tweets are fine elon musk but
you can dramatically change political
and cultural landscapes this way buy and
take over a major social media platform
acquire or create a tv network like abc
nbc or cbs create a world-class online
university and offer degrees for free
that's exactly what we talked about in
the interview can you pull up that
shortcut we replied with interesting
time to pull up that shortcut with
dinesh and i because i fully agree with
that i can i would like to reply to that
tweet i'm banned on twitter so i cannot
do so but i can make a comment right now
go for it my comment is if you're a
businessman
you'd have to you'd have to do it as a
philanthropic thing if your job is to
generate a profit it will not help
if you want to tell the truth if you
want to be a news organization the
commercial imperative
if elon musk is listening the commercial
imperative that is to say poor
for-profit capitalism
is incompatible with investigative
journalism you have to be philanthropic
and by the way this is the way it used
to be you talked about journalism in 70s
and 80s from what i've read
those organizations it was a lost leader
on the company's balance sheet so abc
news would do these things says buy abc
and all these they would do it but they
would do it as a lost leader they would
they would almost donate money on their
balance sheet profit and loss to do the
work it didn't generate a profit per se
but they donated it and if you're going
to buy these companies it's not going to
help unless the person is willing to be
philanthropic the billionaire would have
to uh uh you don't think so you don't
think so i i i believe this yes i i know
so i i don't think and it's self-evident
i mean these billionaires settle
lawsuits i don't know if i agree with
that because because then you're saying
then you what you just said is that the
current mainstream media has zero
influence and they do mark benihalf
bought time magazine that's a pretty
legit one to buy well you know you got
the uh the peter guy about la times you
got the
amazon jeff bezos bob wapo if it doesn't
work why are they buying well maybe
maybe we're talking about different
things i mean to say if you want to do
investigative journalism if you just
want to people opine and speak opinion
and project their political if i don't
know if that's what the next decision
means i don't want to put words in his
mouth but if if the idea is you just
want to buy a network so that you can
project your political views onto your
audience that's not what i'm talking
about i'm talking about doing real
information finding and truth gathering
investigative reporting you know do
those networks even do investigative
reporting anymore i guess maybe nbc
catches the predators or
does what would you do i don't know but
i mean really real journalism requires
philanthropy as well let's transition
into the next story so spotify in the
last 12 months
they've lost 25
of its value okay in the last 12 months
uh spotify stock has lost can you go to
that okay right there spotify stock has
lost nearly 25 percent of its value in
and 40 i was wrong 45 percent over the
past 2 uh year what's going on so what's
the date you see right there from 20
january 21 to today
it went from being 240 250 a share to
now being what 190
a share 184 a share as of can you go to
what it is today just go to what the
stock is today so we can find out and
during this time
uh uh can we find out when they signed
joe rogan put down when they signed joe
rogan spotify signed joe rogan on what
was it may of 2020 i want to say so it's
been a year and a half 2020.
june of 2020 because december 7th was
when he was leaving youtube something
like that when he said he's leaving
youtube what's the date may 2020 you're
right okay may of 2020 they sound good
memory out i'm very proud of that memory
of yours so so then here's what happens
joe
responds yesterday did you see what you
did and i'm assuming you also saw what
he said i just watched it as i was
coming yeah you were commenting on it so
let me kind of read a few of these
things on what's going on and then we'll
get into it so
spotify
joe rogan and spotify um let me see if
it's this one yep joe rogan and spotify
uh spotify removes neil young's music
over rogan's dispute this is an nbc news
story spotify said it has agreed to
remove neil young's music after the
famed single writer said he wouldn't
share the platform with podcaster joe
rogan who has been criticized for
spreading vaccine disinformation they
can have rogan or young not both young
76 said the heart of gold singers solo
catalogs span more than five decades
from his 1969 self-titled album to his
most recent record 2021 barn
young called out the rogan experience in
his letter and they
the danger of spotify enabling the
distribution of potentially fatal
misinformation with an estimated 11
million listeners per episode jre which
is hosted exclusively on spotify has
tremendous influence spotify's
responsibility to mitigate
the spread of misinformation on its
platform and in harry and meghan markle
decided to comment as well they are
spotify to stop kobe 19 misinformation
from spreading on his platform this is
an insider story a spokesperson uh for
arch archwell harry and meghan's
foundation said in a statement sunday
last april our co-founders began
expressing concerns to our partners on
at spotify about the all too real
consequences of covenant misinformation
on its platform spotify shares dropped
12 follow neil young's request and
remove the music from the platform harry
and megan comments followed the decision
by young and joni mitchell to request
their songs be taken off the platform in
some cases a podcast host saying they
won't release new episodes now by the
way here's other names that have come up
william nelson bruce springsteen which i
think he sold
his catalog to sony for half a billion
dollars i don't even know if he can say
that sony decides whether they want to
take it off i think barbara streisand
queen paul mccartney rolling stones
david grove joni mitchell pearl jam are
removing their music wood spot of from
spotify and solidarity
solidarity and keep in mind that 30
percent of all the buys of music is on
spotify so if people want to buy a song
by snoop
30 of it is bought on spotify so it's
not like it's a small amount of people i
can keep the fascists let's just there's
no there's no
there's no proof to this comment right
here these artists there's a hundred
percent proof to neil young and johnny
if you go i don't know if this is true
no no no go type in bruce springsteen
spotify if you if you type in bruce
springsteen and spotify that's all you
got to do cause that's what i did
yesterday
type in bruce springsteen and spotify
okay right there
it's an nbc story
guitar it's not him yeah so so okay so
these stories are coming out what are
your thoughts on this uh james i've got
i've got
many thought i mean
it goes back to i'm sorry to get
philosophical again but it goes back to
this concept about what is
misinformation because i i watched the
rogan reaction on instagram as i was
driving to your studio this morning i
i'm glad i did
and he and he said this anecdotally said
well things a year ago or six months ago
what the cloth mask you would be banned
if you said it well now it comes out as
true from the experts so it goes back to
this definition of
why are they why are they censoring why
they want him off because of
misinformation what does that even mean
and what it means is it goes back to
in from the authorized experts say
business so the the government the cdc
the experts the pharmaceutical companies
it goes back to what the experts say but
who are these experts
and and it goes back to the very idea of
what we're talking about this whole this
two-hour segment which is the
unauthorized information it's our world
is becoming such that you are only
allowed to think and say what the
authorized knowers
and the presumed credible sources
permit you to say which is so it's so
anathema to
what
journalism and the media is supposed to
be and rogan said he said you couldn't
even say these things a year ago that
now you're allowed to say you know i
want to tell a dirty joke not too dirty
though and by the way i'm happy to say
this publicly and privately you're i'm
i'm um i'm in my um
i'm not married but let's for this joke
let's say that i am and uh i'm i'm in my
bedroom and i'm having an affair with
this beautiful woman and one night
this woman comes into my bedroom and she
goes oh my god how could you do this you
how could you do this you were been
married for 10 years
and and she's looking at me having this
affair and the next morning and she said
how could you do that to me and i said
well honey um that's actually been
debunked by experts familiar with the
matter
experts say that that you never saw that
happen right
so my question is disinformation this is
a rhetorical question disinformation is
based upon
experts and credible sources
um and that's the problem with with our
modern ecosystem is that you can't say
anything contrary to what those experts
tell you
what do you think is going to happen
with spotify and joel long term like
do you see is there any chance that
spotify is going to make a big decision
danny elec is
do you see anything happening there the
only thing that they've come out and
said was that they're going to add
content advisories
to basically joe rogan's podcast did you
hear what he said had to say yesterday
daniel eck he came in and made an
announcement he says
listen i don't agree with plenty of
individuals on spotify okay some i
strongly disagree with
we know we have a critical role to play
in supporting creator expression while
balancing it with the safety of our
users quote unquote we don't want to
play content censor but we are putting
rules in place well this is section 230
this is a central issue here this is the
white house quote you shouldn't be
banned from one platform and not another
so these these companies can't have it
both ways they can either be platforms
or they can be
sort of they can make editorial
judgments um and once these start what i
saw daniel eck is his name
once you start making decisions to ban
certain things not others and you start
crossing that threshold now you're
effectively a news you're effectively uh
you're not protected by those immunities
and and and you should be sued for
liability these are tough issues and
we've never crossed this rubicon before
this is a this is a today here sitting
here today that we've never gone this
far so i don't know
what the future holds but
i don't know it could all and the other
thing is these ceos of these companies
these for-profit people like eck i don't
know what his values are but if your
value is money and profit
um they're kind what ends up happening
is they're always going to fold they're
not going to be able to stand firm
that's what i think is going to happen
they're going to fold and there's going
to be more censorship and i think it's
bigger than just daniel eck look at look
at uh
twitter and uh jack dorsey you know
people have their thoughts on jack
dorsey but but people who know jack say
that the whole reason he started twitter
was for a free speech ecosystem and he
got pushed out by the board by
executives et cetera et cetera so now
there's talk of him starting his own
platform but what happens with spotify
can can daniel eck hold strong or will
the executives come in the board members
come in and say no we're done with you
thank you very much that's a that's a
great question because listen 45 you
know how much is 45
you're not talking they lost 16 million
dollars you're not talking they lost 100
million dollars or 400 million dollars
you're talking about
billions of dollars okay
billions of dollars their market cap
right there if you look at look at their
market cap right now
what's the market cap of spotify 36.4
billion dollars do you see it do you see
the market cap of spotify 36.4 billion
dollars yes if you're talking 45
what is a drop-off to go to
36 billion dollars that's 70 billion
valuation you talk about they lost
nearly 22 to 24 billion dollars in 12
months we're not talking a little bit of
money so imagine the conference calls
where investors are on and saying how
are you handling
joe rogan what are you going to do about
imagine a board board is sitting there
saying hey like i remember my board we
had a meeting it was a tough
conversation they had with me
what are you doing to get a hundred
percent what are you doing to get your
agents to get vaccinated it's a
conversation i had with me in my board
meeting so i'm sitting i'm having to
have a conversation with them
they've had to have a conversation with
daniel saying what are we doing about
you're also you are also giving a great
lecture for your audience about why i am
a 501c3 non-profit organization which
protects the freedom of association
rights for donors to the first amendment
because we don't have this problem we
don't have to disclose that the supreme
court has protected our right they can't
boycott our donors because they don't
know their names
and this is the problem i'm going to go
back to my argument this is the problem
with
these
for-profit
news because joe rogan is technically a
man who's disseminating information and
news is that it they'll invariably fold
you know and and that's why
i i i don't i
i've seen it
the first chapter in my book is called
suffering
because the amount of pain that this man
is going to that ek is going to have to
endure to go through this
um
i i mean i i think the only way forward
is philanthropic
non-profit sort of uh
the model to get information out there
where they can't boycott and target the
people that support you so as soon as
the uh the hundred million dollar
contracts happen
uh we'll see what happens we'll see what
happens i think so i i don't think
rogan's going anywhere i think rogan's
going to be in demand for a long time to
come i don't think robin rogan's going
to have a problem because
yesterday when he posted a video did you
guys see the commentary on what people
said to him you guys did you look at the
commentary
so let me ask you a question if you go
to rogan's instagram post so check this
out go to his instagram post just
happened in google instagram joe rogan i
want to show you a couple people that
commented
that says who joe is so when you think
about the rock what do you think about
the rock type it right there click on
that what do you think the rock is left
right center where do you put the rock
politically i don't know center-ish well
he he protect he the defended uh what do
you call it uh
uh well o'keefe doesn't see left right
center he's sure
exactly but you know he went out there
and he had the
biting on kamala harrison but he didn't
have trump on right so he supported one
side now while you look at that i'll
read it okay if you can't find it i'll
read it here
so when he posted this video here's a
commentary
uh it got
four million views okay million likes
okay
uh the here's what the rock said the
rock dwayne
johnson said in the comment section
he commented and he said something about
hey man you know
i obviously tulsi gabbard commented i'm
trying to find the rock's comments jewel
commented sure
but there is one from the rock man if
you can't find it i hope he didn't
delete it i mean this thing was up
yesterday uh and something about hey i
can't wait to come on one of these days
and be on the podcast it's crazy that it
hasn't been on yet yeah he said i'd love
to one of these okay there you go great
stuff here brother perfectly articulated
look forward to coming on one day and
breaking out the tequila with you okay
and got 60 000 a comment got 60 000
likes so
he's protected joe is going to be in
demand no matter where he goes
you're saying he's uncancelable
i don't know if i'm going to say he's
uncancelable i when i sat down with joe
my suggestion to him was the only way
you can protect yourself 100 long term
is to do what consider opening up your
own thing for example if he and musk
teamed up together
imagine if him and musk teamed up
together to start something yeah right
yeah i agree with you that was that was
profound you have to be the chairman of
your own company
you have to be the owner and chairman to
be to be a journalist yeah even even
let's take that to the house what you're
doing to be a journalist like that's a
very astute point i i want to comment on
this i didn't start out thinking i'm
going to create a business with 75
employees and 20 million dollar budget
of course i've ever thought i'm going to
do that i said i need to tell this truth
i need to expose this thing and then
along the way i realized okay
in order to not settle the lawsuit i
have to have the autonomy the power to
make that decision no one would have
ever
allowed me to make these decisions
unless i was in control of making those
decisions so you're right i think
i think he has to be the owner and the
controller and right now he's
i guess he's in contract with spotify is
that correct four years he's not on the
board of spotify right not no he's not
well that's oh he's interested but but i
tell you think about it this way the
other day i was invited to a a party
that was going to be in uh miami the
same night and i don't know if you
remember who the party was by do you
remember when i told you where the party
was okay i'll tell you afterwards it's
one of the biggest guys in technology
world who was having a party with
everyone that's going to be there some
big names that were going to be there
i'm going to kind of show you who this
was
and and the reason why i'm saying this
because i think this guy
right here
needs to be involved in this
conversation with joe
and in the conversation with elon musk i
think if they do it together
i think there's some damage that can be
done if those guys were able to team up
together because one you need somebody
understands technology very well two you
have to have somebody that has a lot of
no it's a little bit more than most
technology two you need somebody that
has to know has access to unlimited
amount of resources which who has musk
has and then three you have to have
somebody that's loved admired adored and
it's as much in the center as possible
and this is the guy right if do you
can't get trump involved because it
wouldn't work out if you get a
personality like that involved but
there's three people i think if they
team up some damage can be made on this
side
with joe and some of these names so
anyways uh uh last question for you here
is uh what's the story with you still
being on youtube
why isn't youtube bothering you because
i was looking at your stuff i'm like let
me get this straight this guy's
this guy's still on youtube doing well
on youtube yeah you're still on youtube
and no one is uh saying anything about
you because we tell the truth because
because we we've won every lawsuit
because we're very careful and diligent
and uh i mean that's the only
explanation we haven't lied about
anything to the people we use undercover
techniques but there we are 1.46 million
subs i still we still haven't gotten our
gold google
what do they call it the youtube gold
plaque plaque we got the silver one at
100 thousand um they won't send us the
plaque
oh that's a conscious decision i don't
know i mean we haven't gotten it why
didn't you when did you you've been over
a million subs for about a year when did
you apply to get the gold well they they
sent it to you they sent us the silver
on unasked for when we get a hundred
thousand
um but i know that tim poole showed me
the gold plaque that he got multiple
and i think he used it as a door stop
for his door
uh he puts the gold plaque under the
door i think but um
i don't i don't know um the reality is
that we are very diligent and extremely
careful if you watch our news reports on
the project veritas youtube channel
uh they're extremely professional very
serious and and very diligent so i i
think they're gonna try to find an
excuse
you know at some point it might be like
a copyright violation or you know you
you're on the street and you hear a song
in the radio of a car but they'll take
you off they'll find some bizarre like
they did take us off one of the videos
because we
uh we were doing a report outside in the
street in california and you could see
in the corner of the screen a lamp post
with
with a
number for one of the houses this is
absurd like
news journalists do this all the time
so we're now we blur every license plate
we're so
tediously careful yeah the standards we
are applied to is above any journalism
standard in the history of the media and
for that reason at least so far
they have not taken down our news
reports go to videos go to videos and
type in uh solve for most views go to
the right sort by views the covet go to
the top one the covet one don't click on
it but the covid one which was four
months ago
uh 5.2 million views and by the way it's
if you've never seen it folks you got to
watch that here's the thing
i
that i can't believe that's still up i
cannot believe that's still up because
you know prageru went and sued youtube
and they went back and forth and they
took a lot of their videos down i am
surprised that video has been left
here's another thing as you're talking
these thoughts are occurring to me we
sue people and we win
and to a certain degree i can i think
it's a fair statement to say that they
fear us more than we fear them what does
that mean i sue the new york times for
defamation i got past motion to dismiss
no can you name anybody else that's i
mean sarah palin did but that was in an
opinion section i did it with the news
section so there are very few human
beings that are able to accomplish that
it's like sort of being in the boss
phase of the video game you know like
when you play nintendo like we've gotten
to the boss level and i think that
there's to a certain degree this is
there's an incentive for them not to do
this sort of thing where they ban me for
some some [ __ ] reason because i'm
the sort of man that will sue them and
win
now you might say well there's no legal
theory to do that with youtube but but
they don't know that and frankly maybe
there is a legal theory under section
230 or
a defamation law so what i mean to say
is i actually believe that these
companies
might be afraid to ban me because if
they were to do that they would have to
create some pretext some some erroneous
rule that applies to me but doesn't
apply to the other guy who breaks the
rules all the time i don't
and they're actually afraid
of being exposed for violating their own
rule
this is an interesting psychological
thing and and that's probably the reason
why they haven't taken that down because
of course our journalism is correct and
those things actually occurred and if
the third video there fizer
whistleblower leaks exact emails that
was a pfizer whistleblower who released
emails
of the director of one of the senior
executives at pfizer pharmaceutical
saying in an email these are her words
not mine and she's saying we don't want
our customers to know that we use fetal
cells in the development of the vaccine
and that's what that video was 3.5
million views an actual email is real
evidence
they haven't banned it so why were you
taking off twitter then
great question um uh they said that
twitter's excuse was i was quote
creating fake accounts
now i've never created a fake account so
i sued them for defamation
and that matter is ongoing
they just
seemingly made made up an excuse it
wasn't because my reporting was false
no it's because i quote made fake
twitter accounts
i'm not sure what they mean by that
who came up with the word provocateur
was that something that they used to
describe you i don't i suppose people
but you know when you call on wikipedia
like you have a reputation oh wikipedia
it'll evoke audible gasps from people
who read it that you think i'm a monster
reading the wikipedia page and it's all
just it's all just circularly sourced
nonsense what's your long-term
aspirations what's long term
i think the ultimate vision the vision
of veritas has now evolved into
effectively being the answer to the
question what can i do so we we are a
catalyst for citizen empowerment so we
have as i sit here on my ipad right now
in front of you we have a team of people
that get tips from
uh dms from people instagram dms and
people call our hotline hundreds of
people a day message us and
people from all society you know
military people school nurses cops
honest firefighters
uh everyone and it's effectively
creating a mass movement
of these people on the inside of these
institutions to to to blow the whistle i
would i would love to get more federal
government people to do that um the
challenge we're going to have with
people inside the federal government
like ed snowden and uh julian assange
have shown us that
i think people are going to be
persecuted and and i think that people
are going to have to deal with that
persecution and prosecution um
uh so long term the answer to your
question is we want to create a mass
movement of whistleblowers
mass movement of whistleblowers
of these
whistleblowers yes
uh you and
snowden have you guys ever done anything
together or no well funny enough i was
walking into your studio literally
through that massive bank heavy heavy
ass door
um
it's kind of heavy
when you open it you can't get it creepy
my security detail was like i can't i
don't move the door okay if you think
you're leaving today i feel like i feel
we got you now i feel more unsafe in
this room okay all right we don't want
to see that okay this guy alan
allen's been half asleep the whole time
now he's bossing out uh all right so uh
what were you asking you were talking
about when you were walking in when i
was walking through this
incredible entrance to your studio here
with the bank door
snowden tweeted ed snowden tweeted
a video
of of our performance in miami the other
night
ed snowden was tweeting about the
performance and and i have to say about
ed stone i
this is an example of this both sides
issue is that is he a hero is he a
villain
and i said when this happened eight
years ago i thought about this because
i don't i think he defies
characterization you know he defies
characterization he he what he exposed
was true james clapper lied under oath
the nsa director said we do not
wittingly
you know spy on people is the worst liar
ever for a spook he was giving away all
the the gestures he was rubbing his brow
you're not supposed to do that bad spy
but he defies characteristic but the
amount of
pain you know and persecution he's had
to deal with he's in
russia
he's he's he's um you can't live in the
united states otherwise he's gonna be in
you know solitary confinement somewhere
it's going to require
that level of sacrifice and service and
you might say well who will ever do that
well
our service members go overseas and die
for their country
they do that
is there someone in washington dc
willing to make
willing to live in solitary confinement
for the rest of their life
for bringing disclosures to the public
showing what's actually happening inside
of an organization like the department
of justice is that someone is there a
human being
willing to do that
because i can show you
history is replete with millions of
people who who get killed
for this country
so
i i have a dream where there are people
that come out and hopefully they're not
prosecuted hopefully the disclosures are
to such a degree
that that the people of this country say
you know what we're going to have their
back no matter what and we're going to
elect you out of office if you go after
those people
that that's that's my vision for the
future of this organization and you know
what sitting here right now today
i think it's going to happen good you
seem determined to do it folks if you
enjoyed today's podcast with james
o'keefe
from project veritas hit the subscribe
button if you're here for the first time
and secondly we're going to put the link
below to his book i read this i listened
to it highly recommend you go do the
same as well
uh we're going to put the link to amazon
is that the main link you want us to
drive it to yeah it was number four on
amazon
you want to go barnes and noble or
wherever you want to buy it please thank
you yeah i highly recommend it all
proceeds from this book
go to our non-profit organization that
this this book has sold a lot of copies
it'll probably generate a few hundred
thousand dollars of revenue for us so we
appreciate it goes to pay our reporters
salaries tyler can you do me a favor and
put that in the chat box as well as in
the comments section
on the bottom so people can find the
book having said that james appreciate
you for coming on man this was a blast
thank you
having said that folks this week i think
we're doing a podcast four times right
tomorrow
tomorrow's podcast is with who tomorrow
and hari johann hari which we're going
to talk about mental
uh of
anxiety
uh mental issues you know people are
going through a depression we'll talk
about that tomorrow i think we got
jordan peterson on friday or saturday
stay tuned and i think thursday who do
we have on thursday mr mike written
michael mike ricklin's going to be here
mike ritalin the man's going to be here
as well so having said that stay tuned
folks we're going to do this is going to
be the first week we're doing a podcast
four times having said that have a great
day everybody take care bye bye bye bye
bye
you